I can to this video on playing the
national master cockpit cockpit from
thought you were right yep that's seem
Nets noguera jump no idea don't know the
guy okay let's play the sameish again
doing for complicated player or this you
get really often okay well normally it's
good news if blackest it's not doing
anything against the pin who's in fact
already looks very good for me unless
he's got some some some drastic moves
like him like g5 the apathy has
cancelled all right Ian or never does
that's not that's not all okay I can't
just take now and let's see castles
young probably hard too hard to do it
without castling yeah of course he has
some some some ways to win a pawn on the
queenside but well made this more point
yeah okay let's see Queen Queen how
Queen g4 h4 is pretty good
yeah this is very strong what is he what
is he doing for defense now yeah I've
got a five check now if everything else
fails if i'll check f5 but is this
winning not not so clear it looks it
looks good but is it winning you for the
595 ef5 Bishop f5 check it's probably
not not enough to win
hmm yeah so let's see maybe I need more
more firepower night night here it's
also a good move yeah this is much
better even and now if I jack check so
that after f5 I can't I can enter on f6
and this they know yeah black will not
be able to survive that with the route
involved check threatening Queen h6 with
made Queen a shtick through gauge to
group G a tomato so he needs to move the
Queen now and really really Quincy seven
yeah you must play that and then I need
to to check how to improve there are
ways to do that never quite sure ok so
how to how to get ahead maybe d five
half d5 to take care to have
yeah probably I don't want spend too
much time to get into substantial time
pressure yeah taking here if it takes
f4f 95 this was one idea
yeah I don't see a defense he can take
it six of course but then yeah even
Bishop takes a five minutes probably
winning let's see really this one Bishop
f5 or is the better one now come on it's
probably enough yeah Butchie Thicke's
was my intention here or if I go Bishop
g6 and then takes on e5 yeah this is in
fact also strong taking with tempo and
then rook f1 or we get three who gave
one you can I can you can take everyone
takes e4 is check but it's it's winning
yeah this was okay will gave one to f7
is just stupidly okay I can also play
Queen edge for now okay so let's win the
Queen that should be enough really next
move screen edge form most likely in
twin f6
yeah check check check Joe is really
continuing for quite a while here black
resigned yeah I heard an opening
disaster yeah it's it's it's very it's a
very common picture of people play
against the sameish and don't know any
specific theory there quite often get
under huge pressure I mean but it's a
bit weird that international masters
ignoring Bishop g5 here because this is
a substantial threat you just played
this move very quickly and after Bishop
g5 blacks already in trouble I mean if
he can and he probably should play age
six now if he didn't play that he should
probably do that I mean good or good or
bad you must play that something like
that yeah I don't like it too much but
this is not losing straight away or
leading to big trouble still allowing
Bishop g5 is a bit strange and around
here black is in big trouble we have you
have almost no way to avoid the
weakening of the pawn structure you can
play the e5 but then you have more than
one good good idea castles can also take
and castle or maybe this first black
must play g5 which looks entirely
ridiculous those moves yeah like
blankets in and trouble the way it was
played it's it's it's almost almost
losing I think yeah neither drive took
me it took me far too long actually but
this is a strong
here yeah Knight f6 is even stronger of
course yeah I didn't see that yeah this
move first captain in the Queen so he
needs to move the king and this is of
course even better than the game with
the bishop on d3 free to roam Queen edge
fly this is probably a checkmate the
comp doesn't show it made yet but there
is one hit pretty quickly coming up
alright hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching